EU finance ministers meeting in brussels
on march at the 10th agreed in a
proposal for a european fund for
strategic investments the fund a part of
the commission's plan for europe will
support socially and economically viable
projects in areas such as transport
energy broadband and infrastructure
education health research and risk
finance for SMEs the deal will also
speed up the process of unlocking funds
allowing new investments to begin as
early as mid-2015 no denying that at the
moment europe need for additional
investment return on the back
sustainable growth we all speak deafness
is disrespectful we had an excellent
initiative so I traveled private
investors it'll be fun so is the booth
corporation well steam let's in there
just before serious market layers I'm
fully confident that Europe is united
ministers also took stock of how the
implementation of the banking Union is
progressing in particular they looked
into instruments aimed at dealing with
the recovery and resolution of failing
banks the Commission briefed ministers
on member states economic policies in
line with the European semester the
council also granted a two-year
extension to France to correct its GDP
deficit by 2017